hey everybody it good to be here I gave
a talk here at one of the meetups like
six years ago seven years ago was one of
the highlights of my career so it's good
to be back
this talks called forecasting at scale
and it's kind of like a little bit of a
joke like a bad joke because at scale
doesn't mean like you're everyone's like
Facebook you got a lot of data so like
the hard problem is how do you work with
all that data like here the scale is
actually like people and problems so
that's kind of like what I want to focus
on it's really exciting to be able to
talk about we released this open-source
package profit about a year ago and it's
really exciting to like see it take off
in the community and get all the support
so it's fun to be able to tell you guys
the story about how we built it so I
have the kind of like the acquired the
illness of being trained as an economist
so I think about things a lot in like
supply and demand frameworks even though
I'm kind of a data scientist now and
when I think about projects and problems
at Facebook I think about demand for
solutions so there's tons of different
Kocher on facebook basically like
acquiring problems and trying to figure
out like how we can what the what the
total demand is for like say a problem
like forecasting so for forecasting
there's a bunch of different reasons why
people will demand forecast like they
need to do capacity planning so one of
the biggest forecasters of Facebook is
the infrastructure team which needs to
know like how many servers to servers to
buy how many data centers to build every
goal at Facebook is set with respect to
like a forecast of some kind so you
can't just say like I'm gonna make this
thing go up by 10 percent because it
might have gone up by 10 percent even if
you sat on your ass so people always
make their you know I have to make a
forecast and then we make a goal with
respect to the forecast and you can also
use forecast and do anomaly detection
anomalies are really important when you
have a big company that's hard to kind
of like see what what's going on in
aggregate so when you when you find a
nomally as you can respond to them but
you can otherwise assume things are
going pretty well and also like there's
just like lots of applications for
forecast that we haven't thought of yet
so the problem is that like even once
you have one of these applications
pinned down like the number of forecasts
that you have to make really multiplies
like you end up having to make a lot of
forecasts and that's like one of the
reasons why we have this like scale
problem we have them forecast many
different quantities for many different
units so we might want to forecast for
every country we want to forecast for
every platform or device type so there's
just like lots of different variants or
units of forecast that we want to make
and then we have this problem where like
not many people are actually experts at
forecasting so time series trainings
like pretty pretty unusual like not many
people have like a lot of experience
making forecasts so this is like a real
problem because we need we need to be
there's this huge demand and we have to
meet it with some supply and there's no
real like off-the-shelf tools that are
gonna solve this problem unlike for like
a lot of other machine learning problems
like we've seen today
so here's the supply and demand curve
you're gonna have like your micro
economic theory nightmares but here's
here's the way that I mentally think
about this maybe this is instructive for
you maybe not on the on the x-axis we
have like quantity of forecasts and on
the y-axis we have like the price of a
forecast but the prices before gas
really is like how long does it take you
to make it and make it to the quality
that like that is acceptable and then we
have the supply curve which is like how
we can supply forecasts and and when I
think about projects I always pitch this
idea of like there's a there's a demand
hypothesis and a supply hypothesis the
demand I bought this this is like what
the shape of this curve is like if we
made forecasts easier like how many more
forecasts would people do like would it
really solve a lot of problems for
people and then there's the supply
hypothesis like how far could we shift
that supply curve by improving how
people do forecasts and if you can if
both of those things are all far off to
the right then you generate a lot of
value you unlock a lot of value by
shifting the supply curve if the demand
curve is more shallow then maybe
shifting the supply curve is and isn't
as great or if you can't really shift
the supply curve by like making forecast
a lot easier then you don't get a lot of
value either but you really want both of
those things to be true at the same time
so we need to figure out a way to shift
that supply curve and the answer was to
like automate forecasting as best we
could the reason why we had to automate
it was that people don't like have a lot
of time serious training this is a stack
of a plot of Stack Overflow tags for
questions with different topics and you
can see like everybody's interested in
machine learning they want to build
classifiers they want to build
regression models but time series models
are like not sexy at all like no ones no
one's working on them and in fact like
they're probably among the most boring
statistics classes that you could
possibly take so I don't blame people
for not really wanting to do this and so
we're just not going to be able to meet
the supply or meet the demand for
forecast with a supply of like people
like we're gonna have to figure out a
way to like make it easier to get more
forecast
per person so the solution the supply
curve shift that I'm gonna like that we
worked on was can we like come up with
some way to automate or at least semi
automate make it cheaper for people to
produce forecasts and the key
ingredients there basically that like
find similarities across forecast
problems so they're all kind of
different but maybe there's something
similar about them that would that would
suggest that the same approach could
work try to build a tool that will solve
most of them maybe not all of them like
we're aiming for like an 80/20 rule kind
of thing here so maybe with 20% of the
work we can solve 80% of the problems
make it easy to use and teach people to
use it so we need to democratize this
tool we need to get it in people's hands
but make it like intuitive for them to
use and then finally we can't just have
people sort of like have a black box
that like gets them an answer but then
they can't make any modifications to it
forecasting is a is a field where are
you injecting your domain knowledge into
the problem can really pay off in a lot
of ways so we want to give people the
ability to like not just get blocked
when they get an answer and say like
there's no way forward I think of this
often is like you know when you build a
classifier and your classifier kind of
sucks you have like somewhere to go from
there oh I need new features or any new
data load forecasting problem you get a
shitty forecast you're like I don't know
what to do next we wanted to get people
a path forward so that was this is this
is a sketch of this solution that we
came up with so here's a motivating time
series this is sort of like you know I'm
gonna show you like my technique works
on the thing that it was designed to
work on so it's not gonna like prove
that much but this is sort of like what
we were what we were aiming the kind of
time series we were aiming to forecast
when we started working on profit this
is the number of Facebook events that
are created per day and anybody see any
sort of like just call it out anything
repeatable about this work at about this
time series like why would we be able to
forecast any notable features
seasonality is there a trend kind of
there's outliers why is it spread out
like that
weekday effects yes so we have like
holidays we have seasonality we have
yearly seasonality and weekday
seasonality
and then we have like these kind of like
trend changes and that's the rough shape
of the time series that we're trying to
address but it fits a large quantity of
time series in my experience especially
at Facebook
so here's what happens this is like in
the infomercials when they show here's
what happens if you use the other guy's
product and someone's like really
ineptly like like burning yourself on a
frying pan trying to make an egg okay
this is if you use the forecast library
which is a wonderful library and Rob
Heineman has been like super helpful and
helping us make profit better so I want
to give him a ton of credit for like
having done a lot of the foundational
work and forecasting and he's got two
automated methods in his in his library
one is auto ARIMA and one is exponential
smoothing and they both perform a model
selection process so they're really
trying to like do a lot of work for you
and take a lot of this like time series
black magic out of the process for you
but you would get these like really
crappy forecasts if you had used those
methods on this time series out of the
box and of course like there's ways to
fix these forecasts up and Rob hyneman's
blog is like like it has like a litany
of questions about how to do this and
make it better and it's like we just
can't expect every everybody who's
running forecasts at Facebook to be able
to do all that research to figure out
how to get these things to work and then
like with regard to like intuitiveness
or interpretability
here's what happens if you went to like
help Otto Rhema you'd really be saying
how Oreimo because like because these
aren't really like intuitive answers to
your questions about how to make your
forecast better you'd be like maybe I
need to change this max Peter which is
the maximum value of P and like that's
like it doesn't really help you like or
give you like a path forward to making a
better forecast so your so people would
get really blocked they say like this
forecast package sounds great but it
doesn't work and then they don't know
what to do next so here's all the stuff
that we just talked about there's a
yearly cycle got this weekday
seasonality we have this yearly cycle
then we've got these sort of like spiky
seasonality period so we call those like
holidays or events those happen a lot in
facebook data so like you know like the
Superbowl is a big event
it doesn't really correspond to like
it's not on the same day of the year
every year but it does happen and it and
it is very important so like things like
that need to be accounted for and then
we have these outliers outliers are like
dates when maybe the logging broke or
like double logged things or like
everybody's got and least in my world
like pretty low quality data so your
forecasting method should be robust did
these thing
and try to like capture as much of this
as possible but try to like ignore the
stuff that's not that useful and another
thing that's not pictured here the
profit I think does pretty well with is
like that like a lot of data could be
missing and the method that we propose
like doesn't worry about missing data in
any way so it'll like it'll just sort of
like neatly interpolate over anything
you're anything that you're missing
which is kind of like another common
property of the data that we work with
so how do we model this so like if
you're a time serious person you're
gonna sit down and say like I need to
model the generative process of how this
time series was would be created in some
hypothetical world so and that turns out
to be like really hard thing to write
down a generative model for time series
processes like at each state like a new
thing is gonna happen and it's gonna
depend on the past in some way these
recursive models of time series and we
were like screw that we're not doing
that we're just gonna build a
discriminative model we are gonna fit
curves and it turns out to be a really
fruitful way forward so profit is
actually a simple decomposable time
series model it's a generalized additive
model so each component is additive but
the individual components may or may not
be linear so the first component is a
piecewise trend that can be either a
logistic trend or a linear trend and
that's going to account for basically
like how fast the time series is growing
or declining the second component is
going to be seasonality so that's gonna
be like something that happens regularly
in cycles that recurs and we can have
multiple kinds of seasonality and that's
not a problem because it's a generalized
additive model we can just add new
components and then there's going to be
this Holliday effect so these are things
that are spiky so there's smooth things
that change over time and then there's
spiky things that kind of recur and then
that's basically like all you need to be
able to extrapolate something then
finally there's this like iid noise
which is like anybody who's studied
time-series methods is like rolling
their eyes because this is like the
worst assumption because every time
series class would focus on modeling
this noise component would say like how
does the noise evolve over time and what
we're doing is saying like hey let's
model all that other stuff and like try
to whiten the noise as much as we can so
that like you know we don't have to
worry about the stuff that the normal
time series people spend like you know
500 beige books trying to characterize
okay so we have a couple tricks we use
l1 regular eyes Chen chips in the first
component we use Fourier series for the
second component for the seasonality
component and then we just use dummy
variables for the
holiday effects so there's just like
three little tricks to profit it's not a
fancy model I'm not claiming like I
invented something like groundbreaking
here but it works pretty well so here's
what the profit forecast looks like for
that time series that I just showed you
so this is me showing you like if you
fry an egg with my thing you will not
burn your hand and you'll get a really
beautiful looking egg and of course this
is like the time series that it was
designed for but it performs well on a
lot of other cases and I've got a lot of
feedback from people from all kinds of
different companies who are using it
really effectively so it turns out that
this it's a very biased model like it's
biased toward the kinds of problems that
we have but those problems tend to recur
in the wild a lot like business time
series data tends to have this like
human scale seasonality to it like
people just do things at certain times a
day or certain times of the year and
like and it's repeatable and it's kind
of predictable and that's really what
you want to capture and if you capture
that well then you can capture the
trends really well I'm not gonna take
questions I only have eight minutes so
I'm like all right so what's nice about
an additive model is that it has
components that we can explain so I can
tell somebody why the forecast was the
way that it was so here I'm explaining
the model that I just showed you it's
got a like a piecewise linear trend so
the trend sort of sort of declines for a
little while then starts to increase so
this is like part of the magic of profit
is learning that like there's this like
local trend change that now we're going
to extrapolate from there only then
we've got our weekday cycle so that's
showing people mostly create events on
Mondays but not on the weekends because
they're mostly like attending those
events on the weekends and then we get
this yearly cycle which captures like
what we were we were visualizing the
data we could say like hey there was
this dip during the summer this dip at
the end of the year the early cycles
taking care of that how do we do that
piecewise linear trend or the piecewise
logistic or trend we have this neat
little magic where we we generate a
bunch of candidate change points like
points where we think that the data
might have could potentially have
changed its trajectory and then we put a
little Blas prior on which is like a
sparse prior it's going to assume most
of the time that those change points are
zero but some of the time we're gonna
allow it to change so the data is going
to allow us to like basically data is
gonna tell us when the time series has
shifted its trajectory which is a really
like nice feature so we're learning from
the data like how to extrapolate locally
from the end
kind of modeling the past data as much
as we can so you can see here here's the
posterior Laplace distribution a little
applause parameters that we've drawn for
the time series and you see that big
trend shift at the end so a predict time
what we want to do is like sample from
those future trend changes and what
that's going to basically do is say like
a time series that had lots of trend
changes in the past is going to have
lots of trend changes in the future
that's going to give it really wide
confidence intervals and a time series
that have very few trend changes in the
past like a straight line is just going
to have a very tight confidence
intervals cuz we think it's not likely
to change in the future so here's an
example of what the what the confidence
intervals look like from this procedure
so they're not actually like confidence
intervals because this isn't a
generative model I can't claim that they
have any kind of particular coverage
properties but they give you a rough
sense of like how uncertain you are
about the future from this time series
which is really all that a lot of
business users want to know they want to
know like should I be worried about this
being like super different in the future
or can I be relatively confident so one
of the nice things about profit is that
we provide lots of knobs and levers so
this is the idea here is that like I
want to give you a path forward after
you finish your forecast to like maybe
make up make a change to it and the
reason this is important is that humans
have lots of domain knowledge about the
stuff that they're modeling and they
need to be able to inject that domain
knowledge into the problem to get better
results and so we give people lots of
ways to do that and they're encoded
because it's a it's written down as a
model and Stan as a Bayesian model as
priors on parameters and so if you have
a strong prior that a parameter is close
to zero
then it will like remove that component
from the model so we could say like hey
seasonality this this time serious
probably doesn't have your early
seasonality because it's like stock
market data so you can like turn that
turn that data down to that prior all
the way down to zero and then we'll say
like this parameter is probability 0 and
then the seasonality component just
shrinks out of the model so you get like
a knob there for that how often we
expect change points this will affect
like how Wiggly or how much we over fit
the insert the in-sample data we have
functional forms for growth so you can
have like logistic growth or you can
have linear growth I think people have
been like in the github talking about
adding different kinds of growth
components they're all piecewise so they
sort of like our locally smooth and then
allowed to change at certain points but
otherwise like you can put any
functional form that you want then
there's covariance and holidays so we
allow people to model the data in
various ways if you have covary
it's that our informative or if you know
the dates of certain holidays you can
add those in then you can have custom
seasonality so we we include weekly and
yearly seasonality by default and if you
have daily level data there will be
daily level seasonality but you could
add your own and then importantly we
give people the ability to say whether
they want just a map estimate so profit
will fit most times so you did in about
a second so you can get like a real
interactive workflow going but if you
want to get a full posterior over all
the parameters you can do that you just
have to wait a few minutes and then you
get sort of like full full estimate of
uncertainty so profit is just sort of
like a general answer to the question of
like how do I solve the problem of a lot
of people have a have a common problem
that sort of similar various ways and I
need to democratize a tool to solve that
problem and here's here's the basic
playbook that I think I've I this is
this is what I think plays out in
practice a lot you've probably built a
lot of stuff that looks like this a lot
of our packages look like this you have
your raw data which is like you know
what's in your database and you spend
some time standardizing it so that it
fits some input format so you saw in
Jared's talk like four to use extra
boost you have to make a matrix because
that's what it expects to see profit
just expects to see sort of like a
sequence of measurements over time with
a timestamp and so it has a pretty
simple input format then there's like
your tool is an abstraction layer over
that standardized data so it wraps it
and provides functionality on top of it
like an object so we can say like
provide an explanation for what it found
in the data it can provide predictions
or it can provide Diagnostics about like
how well it fit or like why it fit the
way that it did and this is a really
general playbook is like you just force
your user to make the data look a
certain way and then you provide all the
functionality being willing to assume
that the data looks the way that it does
okay so what's the process look like for
building one of these tools I think that
this is this is the rough playbook that
we went through with profit and I think
I've seen this play out a lot in my in
my career at Facebook it's like there's
this rough research process that goes on
when you're trying to build something
like this and it starts off with like a
hypothetical like could we even solve
this problem is it even possible and so
that's the basic research side then you
get to like something that you might be
able to use and then you build a
prototype and the prototype sucks and it
fails a lot and you work on that on that
phase for a really long time
and I think this is where like stand
came in really handy as a tool because
it allowed us to get to a prototype
really quickly and iterate really
quickly the prototype phase is also
where you want to gather lots of use
cases and try to make sure that you do
well on a number of them as best you can
so that it's more general technique then
you shift to the quality code phase
we're like maybe someone at your company
who's a software engineer can use it so
we had a long phase at profit with
profit we're like the people who are
using it we're like the hardcore
software engineers at Facebook who were
willing to go through the hoops of like
how do I install this package why do I
have to install stand and stuff like
that
then finally we were able to like put a
little documentation together you know
write a lot of use cases and case
studies polish it up for external use
and that's where it became like a tool
like a call something that like people
can use not just like experts and I
thought that was a really big like a big
step function change and like how many
people could use and benefit from profit
that's where the supply curve in that
economics diagram that I showed you
really shifted to the right so the
takeaways from this experience building
this tool or I think that like actually
the forecasting problem was not as such
a technical problem more of like a
people problem like we just needed to
figure out how to get a tool into
people's hands that address their needs
that gave them a path forward that you
know that was intuitive for them to use
and and that like wasn't didn't require
them to be time-series expert and then
we have lots of people that can move
forward on a problem like this profits
is super simple model it's not like
rocket science it's not like you know
you don't need the time series expert to
even develop this in the first place
like a lot of people could have figured
this out on their own the simplicity of
the method is actually a virtue it means
that when it fails it fails in
predictable ways that we understand it's
easy for people to understand what it's
doing and why it's doing what it's doing
and so like I think that even though you
might say hey you didn't invent anything
new I'll say like yeah but it works well
and like people get it and so that's
that's a really nice virtue of a
technique like this and you can apply
this playbook over and over again and
with the kind of problems that show up
at your company I don't think that this
is anything particularly special about
forecasting there's lots of other
statistical problems that like you know
you have to just figure out what's
common about them and figure out what
kind of tool and what kind of interface
will work for most people
so with that I'd like to just sum up
like you can try profit it's open source
you can download it you can submit pull
requests we'd love to see those and we
have paper about it that summarizes a
lot of the thoughts that I just gave you
like in a more
those forms so please read that if you
want to thank you thank you
you